welcome to another edition of us classic
checkmates I am your host 1998 Missouri
scholastic state champion Michael comer
back in 1995 me and a ragtag group
started a chess club over at Bishop
DeBerg High School the anna griffin's
they were the powerhouse and they're
like yeah let's bring these these chumps
down to our winter break tournament
little do they know there was a genius
on hand so let's pick up the action it's
round three I'm the white pieces I'm
cruising to victory I'm attacking this
bishop he's like you ain't taking my
bishop so what did I get instead guess
what the King back row checkmate
giving me this beautiful huge trophy all
right my torment of Vianney was not done
so just three months later in the state
championship I was playing there number
one kid and here it is there a half
point away from winning the championship
but they had to go through me first
so after attacking the knight he
retreats the night only to fall in to
the trap do you see a maiden - I do
queen up six check no matter where the
king goes it's gonna be checkmate if he
would have escaped to g8 not good enough
you see the mate I'm not horsing around
checkmate all right so now it's week one
of junior year he they scheduled it
Vianney
against the bird here we go and that the
slaughters just getting worse and worse
here it is
I'm playing black black to play and
humiliate there's a lot of made in twos
but the best one is a little discovery
action and no matter where the king goes
there's gonna be a checkmate
on g2 me and my ragtag group went in to
the playoffs in the Vianney heavy
underdog
and I wish I could show you the
checkmate when it's just too advanced
for this channel